in the center of our galaxy the Milky
Way there is a supermassive black hole
feeding on nearby stars
it's called Sagittarius a star and if a
giant gravitational monster slowly
eating the galaxy isn't terrifying
enough there's another cosmic
monstrosity lurking around it is it
possible that one day they would get a
little too close and collapse on each
other what would be left of the Milky
Way if they did would there be even a
slight chance that the earth could get
out of that safely this is what if and
here's what would happen if a magnetar
collided with a black hole this
monstrosity creeping through the Milky
Way is a remnant of a giant exploded
star but it's not just any remnant it's
an extremely dense and very magnetic
collapsed stellar core
magnetar let me refresh your knowledge
of magnet ARS they're born when a star
at least eight times more massive than
our Sun reaches its expiration date and
explodes in a beautiful supernova much
of that star is gone but the dense core
of it remains
most of these remnants become neutron
stars they spin very fast usually a few
times per second and they're composed of
neutrons some neutron stars have such
strong magnetic fields that they emit
electromagnetic radiation from their
poles that makes them pulsars and you
can observe them with a telescope when
their poles face the earth only a few
pulsars develop such an extremely
powerful magnetic field they become the
strongest magnets in the universe the
magnet ours they spin once every 10
seconds but their magnetic field is a
hundred times stronger than that of a
neutron star if one of those magnets
came halfway between the moon and
well it wouldn't be pretty but would it
be as bad from a distance of 26 light
years away
well what I'd like to know is what a
magnetar swallow a black hole or what a
black hole gobble up a magnetar the
collision of these two giants wouldn't
end up in an explosion but in a quiet
cosmic merger stretched over billions of
years
although magnate ours are incredibly
powerful they would lose the battle with
a black hole depending on the trajectory
of the magnetar as well as the size and
mass of both the magnetar and the black
hole the magnetic monster would be eaten
up either hole or slowly piece by piece
as the magnetar was being torn apart by
the black hole it would be sending
gravitational waves throughout the
universe disturbing the curvature of
space-time once the black hole consumed
the magnetar its mass would increase and
expand its event horizon and thanks to
this expansion more and more stars would
be flung into its dark density the black
hole would be slowly eating our galaxy
starved by star eventually after
quadrillions of years of star
consumption the black hole could gobble
up the Milky Way all of it
by that time humanity would most likely
be long gone anyway that is unless
another cosmic event disrupts this
feasts some four and a half billion
years from now but that's a story for
another what if
you